any hello everyone and welcome to
today's live broadcast patient number
one pioneering immunotherapy and finding
the best right treatment for Stage four
melanoma presented by TGA sharp we are
excited to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsors authored by roche diagnostics
as a global leader in healthcare roche
diagnostics offers a broad portfolio of
tools that help healthcare providers in
the early detection prevention diagnosis
and treatment of diseases in molecular
diagnostics roche diagnostics is driven
by a vision of working with laboratories
like yours to improve the medical value
you offer in microbiology infectious
diseases oncology and genomics the
company continues to meet unmet needs
through its investment in research
innovation and scientific excellence
with the goal of supporting your
important role in improving patients
live learn more about roche diagnostics
please visit us Diagnostics Roche com I
am Judy or Oracle a bruise and I'll be
your moderator for today's events before
we begin I would like to remind everyone
this event is interactive we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want and anytime you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your question into the box that
appears on the screen will try to get to
as many as we can and will follow up if
we don't have time today also please
notice that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
and finally if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of the presentation window or use the
Q&A button to let us know that you're
having a problem thank you now I'd like
to introduce TJ sharp PJ is sharing his
fight against stage 4 melanoma in his
weekly patient number one blog on
wwe.com / patient 1 he felt sturdy
native and fish
useless and Carnegie Mellon University
graduate currently lives in Fort
Lauderdale Florida with his wife
Jennifer and children Josie and Tommy it
was patient number one in a clinical
trial at moffitt cancer center in Tampa
the first person worldwide to use the
sequence of treatments to fight melanoma
and is currently in a second clinical
trial at Holy Cross Hospital in fort
lauderdale receiving merck anti-tb one
drug ten role is Ahmad restore me in
welcoming TJ I will now turn the
presentation over to him thank you Judy
thank you everyone for tuning in as Judy
mentioned my name is PJ sharp we are
presenting the keynote today pioneer and
immunotherapy and finding the best right
treatment unlike many of the
presentations that labret has done the
last day and a half this one is being
done by a patient actively getting an
immunotherapy in just a few minutes we
are going to hook up myself to my 43rd
dose of key truda also known as temporal
ism app and get a dose of my clinical
trial so my information is right there I
do is to dimension write a blog about my
experiences on patient number one on
philly.com I want to thank first lab
roots for hosting this roast diagnostics
for sponsoring and Holy Cross for
administrating the drug today and the 42
previous doses and the team here excuse
us this was going to be a live broadcast
of the actual infusion but unfortunately
we ran into some technical issues and
well only going to have PowerPoint
slides going for but hopefully it'll
give you an idea of what we're going to
do start with introduction and tell more
about what we're going to do the
infusion will be here momentarily well
you cannot see it we will be hooking me
up in a few minutes to to an IV and
getting getting ourselves infused with a
30 minutes of Merck's Pemberley the map
after that we're going to play a quick
video called the promise of
immunotherapy speaking of pemberley's
I'm Abbott's featured on there as are we
here at Holy Cross and I and as a
patient it'll give you a little more
detail certainly much more than I could
explain about how current immunotherapy
therapies work and from there we'll go
on to a little bit of backstory of what
I've gone through and you know why we've
titled it pioneering immunotherapy and
find the best right treatment this
you'll see the quote I'd be surprised if
he is here in three years and i'll tell
you the story in a few minutes we'll do
something called finding your research
ninja and finding the best right
treatment as a team effort someone told
me once the cancer doesn't affect the
person it affects a family and we have a
little cute little slide about that that
describes exactly or in detail what
we've been able to do kind of as a team
to overcome you know a stage for
melanoma diagnosis and how how that
would be applicable for other patients
to see hear and understand when they're
beginning their journey through a
melanoma or a different cancer diagnosis
well then talk about what life is like
with you know therapy and there's a
quote from one of the doctors here that
said you're using your immune system to
fight cancer so we'll discuss some the
things that we've did we've done and
changed in our lives that allow us to
get the most out of this drug and you
know certainly enhance my chances of
adorable long-term response a lot of Q&A
at the end as UD mentioned so the
presentation should last somewhere
between 30 and 40 minutes and we'll have
plenty of time for questions afterwards
depends on how long this confusing goes
we'll start right now with quick
background again my name is TJ sharp and
when i was 25 i was diagnosed with a
stage 1 V melanoma
being 25 years old I thought this wasn't
a big deal we got it surgically removed
and the doctor told me to stab the Sun
there's a fifty percent chance that you
get melanoma again in your lifetime so
it was hat long sleeves sunscreen and a
move from New Jersey to Florida they try
to keep me out of the Sun as best as
possible fast forward 12 years later we
just had our second child my son Tommy
and I went into the hospital with what I
thought was a spiking fever the doctor
that mitad admitted me looked at my
x-rays of the chest understood my
history of melanoma and said with your
your history of cancer we think you have
a recurrence of your of your melanoma
and you know I I told him I go work
we're here for the spiking fever not for
the melanoma unfortunately the doctor
was right and
kicked off a three-year and Counting
Odyssey that saw us have go through to
clinical trials for immunotherapies and
six different surgeries beginning with
one that hospital stay to remove a nine
centimeter tumor one of the things that
we have focused on is getting better and
not just prolonging time on here so
we're very happy to report quickly that
currently I'm considered stable disease
with two spots remaining on CT scans PET
scans have shown to be very clear with
no detectable cancer in their soul I I
can't get the de coveted no evidence of
disease status we we certainly believe
the team and you know I believe as a
patient that we are we are going to win
this one and it's just a matter of time
before those spots either disappear or
turn out to be scar tissue or something
to decide to cancer cells the tumor
burden is less than fifteen percent of
what it was before and we're hoping that
that is really non-cancerous spots on
there I've also been fortunate enough to
share my journey with with the world
seems but at least with a small amount
of readership in the Philadelphia area
and whoever's billion but pick it up
with with a blog post started just as a
way of letting the family and friends
know how I was doing it is turn into
something that has enabled me to
interact with caregivers patients
doctors advocacy groups and really
understand that what is going on in the
cancer research world it's being
pioneered by some of the treatments I
have is pretty remarkable and you know
it's a very small silver lining that
I've been able to somewhat influenced or
someone to help others who are starting
their journey after mine and been able
to read and see that
this isn't the death sentence it was
just a few short years ago so we're at
this point we're gonna start the
infusion we're actually willingly
medicine down now so we won't have it
for a few minutes and luckily were not
broadcasting that video right now so
what we're going to do is there is a
video called the promise of
immunotherapy done by the melanoma
Research Alliance Judy if you'll be so
kind as to as to start this for those of
you viewing at home you will open in a
different window so when it closes up
just come on back and we'll resume the
presentation
you
you
Oh
as muted so we have a minute or so we've
actually
there was a good kitchen then go on to
their I could be here
okay thank you everybody for coming back
I hope you enjoyed that video and the
description of history of immunotherapy
and where it's poised to go in the near
future in the research world give you a
little bit more about details about my
story as a picture of me and my family
you could see the little little guy is
only four weeks old at this time this is
record for my first surgery in August of
2012 yeah like I said earlier I went in
for a striking fever and emerged 16 days
later minus 19 centimeter tumor and with
other tumors found in both long as my
liver and my spleen we met with the
oncologist after the surgery and he was
a nice guy in general oncologist and
certainly was not a melon I'm a
specialist in he looked at the
tumorigenic genome sequencing and NS a--
sheet and said well this is your this is
your tumor and here's your George
actually should probably have the car
bozena which is a standard chemotherapy
for melanoma good luck and my wife who
is sitting right next to us said okay
well what do we do we talking here
docked what's with the real prognosis
and he kind of all handedly very
casually said well I be surprised if
he's here in two years and as I handed
the tissues over to Jen I mean I started
making a list of things I was going to
do and be here in two years I was at the
very top of that list one of the things
that we decided that day was that we're
not going to just settle for what was
the standard of care or was just the
suggestion we made so you know we we got
24 opinions before we finally found a
clinical trial that would that we felt
suited us best and during that sort of
interview process if you will one of the
oncologists told us that there's a
treatments that would give us many
months you know and I
stopped him and said that's that's nice
and that's not for me you know I have a
family to take care of the family that
needed me here many months wasn't going
to be an option you know prolong in life
for a little bit was it what we were
looking for so we went in search of more
personalized medicine and we found them
you know therapies just as they began to
take off in the melanoma world with no
known really being at the forefront of
these therapies we also knew that for a
best chance at adorable long-term
response we were we were looking for the
cutting edge medicine and luckily it
found it in a tilt trial and a clinical
trial and insisted we had till trial so
we enrolled in a chill trial Moffitt
Cancer Center in tampa florida real
quickly for anybody who doesn't know
what till is which I'm assuming is
majority of the audience it's
tumor-infiltrating lymphocytes it's a
form of adoptive cell transfer where
cells with chicken a love you modified
or duplicated in some form and then
reinserted to fight a disease such as
cancer it's really pioneered not by
myself but by dr. Steven Rosenberg at
the NIH and only a handful of facilities
in the world perform adoptive cell
transfer and even less I believe six or
seven do this particular type of therapy
called till so we found when we thought
was the best option as we were looking
over the consent form began speaking
with the doctors saying okay well how
has everybody else you know how have
other patients fared on this and the
oncologists both looked at each other
looked at us and said as far as we know
you'll be the first patient to try your
voice until combined together and I look
at them and said okay that's great that
means no one's ever failed this before
so we signed on with
after a few hurdles which I'll hear
about as well and we began the till
trial what happened there was a few kind
of false starts in the way but we were
able to start till in January of 2013
you've never seen 65 billion t cells
before open that little bag right there
and you will see the best t cells i had
that would flex answer at least my
version of melanoma if you'll excuse us
just one second we are actually
verifying that we have the right you
know therapy treatments that we are
hooking up my IV right now and will be
starting this momentarily okay know
everybody in the world knows my birthday
so excuse us there for the for the delay
but we are we are about to hook me up
and you won't really notice anything I
shouldn't it's a very simple 30 minute
infusion that you kind of saw in the
video reconstituted through an IV my my
wonderful nurse / guardian angel big
sister Kathy over here has been doing
all my infusions and we've been doing
this so long she's even got a promotion
now so she came back to did the infusion
one last time so like I was saying sorry
for the interruption there what happened
was we put these T cells in went through
eight rounds of high-dose interleukin-2
to support them really went through a
lot you know was in the hospital floor i
believe it was ten days or so and guess
what not only was i the first person to
ever try this combination of your voyant
till I became the first person ever fail
this combination of your boy until so
here i am in March of 20 2013 50 pounds
lighter than I was seven months before
when I checked into the hospital having
already undergone this right here we
have been my fourth surgery and
with tumors growing pretty rapidly and
pretty expansively in quite a few areas
so we decided it was time for Plan B and
luckily we had we had already done some
research in search there we go and the
geology is going in again sorry for the
you're not able to experience this on
video but we aren't we are connected in
TD one speaking of we are connected to
our pd one right now and this is a trial
dusablon given give me the best chance
of that durable long-term response the
problem was is that we couldn't get it
and at moffitt cancer center there was a
delaying getting it there and you'll
hear in the moment why we were a little
apprehensive and we we're going to find
it at a smaller but still very good
Cancer Center here local in Fort
Lauderdale just about five miles from
our from our house so we went home you
know we had been in moffitt in the
Moffat campus synced apt area for almost
four months we were able to come home
and start the timber ilysm m trial in
april 2013 good thing is is that we
started the drug and I got randomized
onto the to the trial drug there was a
third of an arm that is chemotherapy we
were significantly extremely happy that
I was able to start one of the two doses
either the higher and low dose of
September ilysm AB so don't know which
one it is and there was a lot of anxiety
the first few doses we didn't know what
to expect you know how I would react to
it to the drug and it was so new that we
really didn't have a lot of a lot of
feedback from other patients they just
had some of what Mark had provided us so
imagine our surprise when we saw was an
immediate tuna reduction we had two
tumors riya to tumors in my my neck
glands that that you could see and
within weeks you know four or five weeks
have started treatment the tumors track
noticeably and it took us 12 weeks you
know on the on the study protocol to go
through and understand you know be able
to actually get a CT scan when we did we
found that there's a forty six percent
drop in the first 12 weeks and we
continue to drop and drop and drop until
we hit the level we're at about a year
and a half ago which is the four
centimeters or so that's left in in two
spots we did have a little bit of a
hiccup in the road that summer adrenal
gland popped up and the I was fortunate
enough to understand but also for civ
nothings to have good guidance from the
oncology team here to say we don't know
what this really is you should really go
back to moffitt and and talk to them and
get an opinion from from moffitt and mop
it was even know keeping with the same
mantra they said well you know the best
k you can get for something like this
would be it MD Anderson in Houston they
can actually remove this tumor and thank
it for a potential plan see down the
road for potentially as a tilt another
till therapy that could work or could
give us a response if for some reason
the pd-1 stopped working so the the
fifth of my six surgeries was an adrenal
gland removal last summer and it allowed
us to have sort of in the bank that
there is there is an option it's
something stops working so part of what
you've heard so far in this is your
ninja and a friend of mine recommended
that that's my friend ninja right there
that's not really him but I do have a
friend whose nickname is ninja Don and
he has been as bad as you know amazing
as a friend could be or someone could be
to help facilitate Mike hair when I was
first hospitalized he were going to
communications both with doctors with
family members and other friends he's
continued to help ask questions to the
point where you know he's become one of
the vital cog for the support system so
we titled this part of it you know
finding your ninja because of the the
Chi little name but really what that
means is it that every patient is going
to go through a diagnosis and treatment
be of melanoma or some other type of
cancer does need to find that person or
that team of people that will function
you know as she did it is quite a few
others of my family and friends did I
was lucky on many levels that I had such
a good support network that we weren't
worrying didn't have to worry about the
newborn in the house you know that
people were willing to watch we were
able to go to a place like Moffitt and
stay there and were supported by family
and friends along the way we had people
who were able to call doctors and do
research for us when either I wasn't up
to it or we just needed a break you know
as for the for the doctors and medical
professionals out there listening that's
one of the essential things to my
recovery and it's certainly something
I've heard from other patients that has
been a key in theirs so I would
encourage you to proactively push your
patients to identify those family
members that can offer the right kind of
support not the kind that drags you down
but the one that does the work in the
background so that you can folk that the
patient can focus on becoming healthy I
was lucky in a way that I worked in the
pharmaceutical field when I was sorry
about that when I was young and I knew
what a clinical trial meant I knew what
that it wasn't just being a guinea pig
and that mostly most of the
breakthroughs were happening in the
clinical trial world I was very
fortunate that when the first trial
started
we had people that new friends at
bristol-myers because the first trial
was waiting on a final stamp of approval
from their legal department and they
rights just you know rightfully so
wanted to ensure that all the keys were
crossed and the eyes were dotted but in
that time my cancer is getting worse and
it finally took me to get the phone and
calling bristol-myers and saying this
might be your job but this is my life
and went to LinkedIn and found a few
friends who worked with someone at
bristol-myers or knew someone there and
had him actually you know call their
friends and say is there anything you
can do to speed this up two days after
that we got a call from the oncologist
at moffitt saying we don't know what you
did it's you you found a way to make
this this work they call today and they
said your trials approved so I was
fortunate that I was able to do that and
I had enough friends and family that it
could help speed along the process
doctors and lots of the medical
profession are very overburdened than
you you want to be the only patient and
it's great when you find a facility or
an office or a practice that can treat
you that way but you know as a patient
you also need to realize that you are
just one of dozens sometimes hundreds of
other patients and you're owning your
health care is something that I've
certainly pushed on others and I think
that patients would be wise to
understand that right away that they
have a responsibility to push their
doctors and their team to get the answer
that they need finally the last thing
about having a great team is that there
are people that will push the stuff for
you there our advocacy organizations out
there you've heard from a couple of them
today the melanoma Research Alliance
the results Research Foundation have
both presented earlier today and both
along with a few others are great
organizations I was lucky enough that
someone found one of them for me early
on and unfortunately just did not
connect with them but was fortunate
again that they did to find me and
actually connected me to Holy Cross in
this trial so early in fact that the
yeah the first person we talked to he
didn't realize that the trial had even
started they were still waiting on the
papers so where we seem to be the
forefront of giving trial started when I
did start my pd-1 trial here Luke who
you saw in the video is the pharmacist
in charge of mixing the drugs and he and
I talked for a little bit about the side
effects about how I would end up feeling
and what would what would the drug would
do to me you know I was at the time if
you remember that picture 180 pounds and
certainly had been through seven months
of different you know different
therapies and surgeries and was not in a
very you know strong strong state you
know mentally or physically and he told
us one thing and the context was you
know you should be fly during treatment
we tell us one thing that is sort of
echoed with us for the last few years
and that is that you are using your
immune system the flight cancer do
whatever you can to keep that
functioning at its optimal level and
that sunk in that really became you know
it's it's easy to see the headlines
about communities but until you really
become a patient and understand what
immunotherapy is doing and what you saw
in the video you don't realize that that
all it is is unlocking brakes and to
someone out if if you don't take
anything else away from today take this
away if you are a patient or if you are
a doctor give this to your patients that
immunotherapies don't be cancer directly
the immune system does you know
therapies simply provide the opportunity
for your immune system
to do do the battle image or to do the
job it was supposed to are designed to
do and that is remove cancer cells from
your body in that regard my family nine
changed the way that we lived we we sort
of adopted a much better diet you know
this is nothing new that you've probably
heard about any more vegetables eating
less red meat for four years and years
but we took that to heart and we focused
not on just getting healthy but being
healthy and there's a difference there
much like if you change your diet versus
just going on a diet you know our focus
became being healthy we changed the way
that we lived focus the nutrition put we
put into into my body into our bodies
and became much more aware of some of
the stuff that wasn't as good that we
tried to reduce or eliminate we reduce
stress we leave me especially primed to
rest which was something that you know I
think became very evident after the
first infusion or two that this medicine
works but it also does take a toll and
fatigue is the biggest side effect so we
change the way that we lived and
eliminated not just some some obvious
obvious barriers to being healthy but
ones that weren't learn is as waiting to
see we planned downtime started playing
relationship time even date nights just
for my wife and I had to give us a
little bit of a break from our two
wonderful energetic children we focused
on people instead of you know things or
events relationships became a little
more important and the time that we had
with other people became more of a
priority and those things I believe
really know they they're not going to
answer but they enable your body to
focus on on what it's supposed to be
doing and that's healing so we also did
a little bit in the way of alternative
and complementary
mentary treatments this is certainly a
much debated topic we were given very
good guidance by the ER doctor that
admitted me for the first time about
changing our diet about incorporating
things like medicinal mushrooms that
were you know just supplements you can
buy that boost into your immune system
and once we understood the connection
between what i was doing medically and
what i was doing with my body we geared
towards the things that we knew that
were proven scientifically to offer
better health benefits to be immune
system boosters that cancer patients
would that benefited cancer patients
vitamin c curcumin eating cruciferous
vegetables garlic and onions were on
with in the morning which doesn't always
make you smell great but I'd certainly
helps fight cancer onion ginger tea with
some lemon like those things became a
way of life like I said earlier it
wasn't just getting healthy but being
healthy and we really adopted that as a
way to live and we certainly don't live
like that one hundred percent of the
time there's birthday cake there's
treats but if we can be healthy most of
the time and that will allow my body to
fight with with this drug and it's
certainly well out those times that we
do give ourselves a little bit of a
break to be way that much better so to
live with immunotherapy there are a few
different things that are important to
note quickly go through this slide
there's a list on the next one but it's
not just physical there are mental and
emotional hurdles to clear I here quite
a bit that you you look great and I
heard that I've heard that all along but
I think people actually mean it this
time on but there are still it I am
still you know fighting cancer and we
still go for skins every 12 weeks I
still come here
and get an infusion every three weeks so
this is certainly not a done deal or a
victory at this point so that does take
a mental and emotional toll and it's not
just on the patient it's on the
caregivers the family and we talked
about earlier that you know cancer
doesn't affect the person it affects
that family there's no one it affects
more than a spouse or a parent or a
child who is taking care of a cancer
patient and it becomes a difficult
battle for everyone so living with
immunotherapy doesn't just mean that hey
you look good it's a pretty easy
infusion it means you still face those
doubts I and nagging worries that you
know this might only last for months my
only lasts for a few years am I going to
have something show up on a scanned and
you don't know and there that's process
of dealing with the unknown and the
apprehension that comes along with it
isn't easy to do and luckily there's a
lot of organizations out there that will
help advocacy organizations for for any
type of cancer along with you know very
generic cancer organizations like the
the ACS or a Gilda's Club or any other
organization that does that focus and
mission is to support patients and their
families so don't if you are if you are
a patient don't feel that you cannot ask
for help or it's not available there are
people out there that will give you
everything that you need for doctors and
other medical professionals it's hard to
find these things it's hard to know
what's what especially in the early
stages of a diagnosis if you are able to
steer a patient towards a few trusted
websites or a local group or our
national group that you know provides us
very solid and can you support that is a
very good thing for a person in
immunotherapy use on this sort of you
know leading heads of
cancer treatments and doesn't know
because you know there's not enough
information out there what to expect
effects a day our daily lives too um
it's certainly not always easy being the
know the 40 old dad in the room with
cancer and we try as much to make it as
as normal for our our family our
children as possible and i participated
in as many as much as i can and that i
think has helped us you know mentally
and emotionally deal with this but there
are just little things like you know
going to the food store you know it's a
different way of shopping going on trips
you know are planned around the
infusions that i have here are the
doctor's visits anything that comes up
medically you know you if you get a
headache or a fever and if you are
anybody out there you might just going
went to the drugstore grab something you
know as a cancer patient as a clinical
trial participate you know it's my
responsibility to my doctors know what
affecting me because not only is it
business in the ground but this is going
to be used to help others down the road
deal with their their side effects and
we learn about these you know every few
months a few new feet of one's come out
so that lead you to what can I do or
what can I do and part of the reason i
describe this when we first started my
cancer battle a very well-meaning friend
gave us a list of foods that i shouldn't
shouldn't eat and the list of things
that could eat was not very long
probably posted size and the things i
couldn't eat or should we got to get any
longer and i didn't deal well with i see
any PS i can t dad i finally said tell
me what I can eat so let me focus on
getting better in that spirit here are
the few things that more generally that
a immunotherapy patient can I can't do
can live healthy we talked about that
last couple of slides and they cannot
expect the medicine to do all the work
as a patient you need to be proactive
with your diagnosis proactive in your
treatment and for active in your
lifestyle so all the healthy stuff I
talked about before and compasses both
the good things to do and eat and the
reduction or elimination of some of
those things that that maybe won't be
treating your immune system as kindly
and that's part of the thing that as a
patient if you want to survive and
thrive you focus on both the good and
the bed you can be well informed patient
but you cannot expect your doctors to
know everything they are very well
trained very well educated in very smart
people but like I mentioned before they
all have practices and businesses and
hospitals or research facilities to run
they don't know it also there's a
responsibility for you to proactively
understand treatments and their side
effects and not believe everything you
read on the Internet we've talked about
research and it's difficult to say
believe this and believe that especially
says this is actually on the internet
right now so you can believe us but
there are a lot of things out there and
if you start relying on dr. Google it's
going to get it's going to drive you
crazy and certainly make you a confused
patient so being proactive in
understanding the treatment and
communicating with your medical team is
vitally important 10 rest and heal just
touched on that and let inertia set in
stay active when I started my second
treatment my wife asked one of our
friends if hot yoga was okay and since
then you know I've never really looked
back and I've made that part of
something that I do try to do
religiously a couple times a week and
many thanks today to the yoga join for
supporting me in getting my mind and my
body healthy outside of the doctor's
office
and not suiting that sofa or not sitting
in front of the computer and just
worrying about wives the one stuck with
cancer or reading on different treatment
things reactive don't let yourself just
get bogged down by a treatment or
diagnosis you can focus on getting
better we talked a lot about what that
is and you cannot continually worry
about getting sicker the reality is that
many cancer patients will struggle with
their diagnosis and certainly will
struggle with getting to the holy grail
of no evidence of disease and more more
people than not right now that are
wearing my shoes still will not make it
as far as I mean it and that's something
that researchers are really trying to
change it's going to take time but you
can't worry about that you can't sit
there and well on that because if you
continue to do that the chances of being
one of those statistics are going to
going to increase focus yourself on
getting better and enjoying the
happiness around you related you can't
have down days it's certainly okay I had
one of my worst days from my daughter's
third birthday party where I couldn't
make it through her birthday party and I
threw up and I passed out and I remember
thinking is this it and you know that
day I kind of said okay cancer you view
of this day you're not going to get me
tomorrow you know I'm going to come back
tomorrow and that's going to be a
different day so you cannot expect to
just be normal you know this isn't a
normal thing this is difficult this is
hard this doesn't allow you to just do
what you want when you want but it's
something that can be overcome as long
as you recognize it that it is a
challenge and it is a a successfully
assignment it is something that if met
head-on and be can be beaten
last thing you do is stay strong I've
always signed off my emails other
patients with this phrase and it's not
easy to stay strong what cancer patients
go through what they do I it's not easy
but it's them it's very simple get
healthy stay strong Vita for the ones
you love absolutely cannot cannot cannot
give up hope in the last we'll wrap this
up pretty quickly in the last year and a
half what I've been able to do I took my
kids on a five-mile timed race it was in
the video too and I finished that one I
fulfilled a promise to my college
roommate in a couple another friend and
my brother-in-law to do it a tough
mudder 10 and a half miles and a bunch
of obstacles those are the things that I
set out to do and someone asked you know
why do you do this and my answer then
was because I needed to know that I
still could and I can and that's one of
the biggest things I think that has led
me as my attitude towards this so you
know three years later the doctor that
said I'd be surprised if you're here in
two years that now turned into this
little little man isn't so little
anymore and my two-year-old is now a
five-year-old kindergarten girl and
we're still together as a family and
there's not one person missing out of
that so when the doctor said I'd be
surprised if he's here in two years I
was glad it gave me honest mystics
because when you deal with this you
learn three lessons you learn that your
you don't just take the first option
given do your homework and find the best
right treatment I set a goal that day I
was going to be there for two years and
many more and the last thing I learned
was certificate istics are not sentences
and even if he was technically correct
that he'd be surprised if I was here in
two years I wasn't going to let that
dictate what the outcome of this is
going to be
oh I'm going to close with two things
that I that I've seen you'll note the
word Scott recently passed from cancer
said you beat cancer by how you live why
you live in the manner in which you live
and the other quote from the late Jim
Valvano that I've had above my bed or or
next to my office since my first
diagnosis when I was 25 is cancer can
take away all of my physical abilities
but it cannot hard to touch my heart
cannot touch my touch my mind can I
touch my heart and it can not touch my
soul seeing those examples of people
arriving even though they lost their
battle that those are what I'd like to
live my cancer battle by and hopefully
I've done Stuart and Jim proud so with
that I thank you for participating I'll
take any questions and answers in the
short time we have left and hope you
gained something out of this thank you
thank you TJ for that informative
presentation it is time for Q&A if you
have a question you'd like to ask TJ
please do so now just click on the green
Q&A button at the lower left of the
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click on the send button and we'll
try to get to as many as we can and
follow us we don't have time today and
we'll give people a few moments to
formulate questions
if there are no questions I would like
to once again thank TJ for his
presentation to do you have any final
comments you'd like to share with us
today I think I ended up with what I
wanted to talk about with with the
Stuart Scott and Jim Valvano comments I
do appreciate lab roots having the
patient perspective as it sometimes
isn't as noteworthy or as newsworthy so
I think hearing that certainly from one
patient for all the patients out there
is appreciated for you guys including
this in the in the presentation today
and well stay where you are cuz i have
question for you here when did you have
your first pet scan and was that clear
even though you may have had other
manifestations we had a PET scan when I
was first diagnosed in August of 2012
for the next one wasn't almost it was
almost two years to the day later before
the adrenal win removal CT scans were
the norm for both clinical trials so you
know with the ct's measuring size we
continue to see stuff but they did do a
PET scan to see how far the adrenal
tumor had spread and we got very very
surprising news so I think that you know
going forward you know a mixture of the
two is certainly an appropriate way to
measure how how I'm doing in palliative
patients do well thank you for sharing
that and all that your share today I
would also like to thank our sponsor
roche diagnostics for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through March 2016 you
will receive an email from lab groups
letting me know when this webcast will
be available for replay pls sure that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us we hope to see you again soon bye